i want to jump to this next story
because the most important story of our
generation
the hill opinion aoc is the democrats
best shot against trump in 2024. um
ladies and gentlemen i agree go wild i
completely agree i i agree 100 percent
there is no one that i think in the
democratic party that has any kind of
gravitas or media poll i don't think any
of them can win gavin newsom looks like
american psycho aoc can't win either but
best shot agreed trump couldn't win
either remember that in 20th it's true
i i would love to see aoc when i just i
think she's going to be more likely to
engage with libertarians and third party
candidates too really i think she is
i think she can't help herself she can't
stand the people that are bought off
that's i don't know i don't i don't know
i
might be moving in that direction but
but we'll see we'll see i don't know
that for sure i mean i think this would
be a gift to the gop and the libertarian
party ah they they remember what they
said about trump the piedmont yeah right
yep they were like no one will vote for
this guy i think aoc is their best shot
i still don't think she can win she will
just turn 35 before the election
but considering here here's the here's
the deal folks
the economy is in the gutter the misery
index is through the roof
none of this is gonna is gonna is gonna
make it work for the democrats now by
2024
okay maybe the republicans win in
november and then they just
royally screw things up then aoc comes
in and she's like i'm gonna do all this
wonderful free stuff and then maybe she
wins because you got to consider this
it's a couple years from now
you've got new young people and entering
the voting pool and you've got older
people aging out so every every election
you see a shift
that that
that changes the older folks are way
more conservative than the younger folks
gen z is a little bit more conservative
in some areas but they're nowhere near
as conservative so in two years you lose
a decent amount of boomers and you gain
a slightly larger amount of progressives
how about a desantis versus aoc match-up
yeah just you know cool conversation
i would love to see aoc win because it
would be as funny as trump winning i
wouldn't be a fan of what you would try
to do to be completely honest but it's
like but hey gridlock you'd have uh
republicans holding congress yeah if we
had total gridlock it would be wild i'm
just you know when trump won the first
time i had my feet up and i was just
laughing my ass off yeah so
i bought an extra bottle of port in
2016. i was drinking port at the time
that was my thing
and um
when he won florida i was like it's
going to be a long night
i didn't look at the news at all when i
was at work on election day i just
didn't want to know i was too depressed
about hillary clinton winning and i got
home and turned on the news and i was
just laughing hysterically that it was
this was actually reality
i felt like someone a ghost punched me
in the gut i woke up at like 3 a.m and
checked i was like what the [ __ ] is
going on
yeah i remember my my australian friends
social media post that's the only thing
i remember from from the day the results
were announced it just said lol america
and that was exactly how i felt
someone someone super chatted as do not
speak of satan else the devil might
appear re-aoc
and my attitude is kind of like look man
i feel like if aoc were to get in it
would just be better than what we
currently have with the uniparty
establishment like biden and i don't
think it would be good but i would laugh
when aoc won against crowley i laughed i
was like good good riddance to these
these establishment she'll you know i
don't care
aoc has proven in my opinion to be
duplicitous deceptive deceitful
fabricating stories on january 6 and all
of that stuff
i still would rather see her
than any one of these establishment deep
state whatever uniparty trash shells
she's a pretty good actor right i think
it would just be hilarious
handcuffs on for a while she lies just
like all the rest of them so it's not
it doesn't make her worse unfortunately
they all of them lie well i'm just
saying it would be clown world times 10.
yes wouldn't it come on it would be
funny to have president ocasio-cortez i
embrace clown world
i do not reject clown world i embrace it
it's like look if you can't get trump to
come in and try and clean things up you
can get aoc to burn it down i guess
let's burn it
[Laughter]
if that's what people want i think it'd
be funny a righteous fire a righteous
healing fire righteous but but this is
what they do on the left they they
literally riot no we don't want any of
that stuff you know donald trump coming
in you know i want him to fire everybody
oh yeah please don't burn it literally
let's just let's just um destroy it
ideologically and make it into a joke
i'm imagining aoc she's sitting at like
the situation room and the cia comes in
they're like miss madam president we
have these uh
kill lists the disposition matrix these
are the people we got to assassinate and
she's just like
no and they're like you have to and
she's just like i don't know i don't
know i don't think i wanna what is this
and then it's just like how do you how
do you work how will look when when they
go to obama here's what i imagine
cia goes to obama and says sir
we have these these wanted men here's
what they've done we have a chance to
take them out this is in line with
foreign policy it must be done and he
goes okay
launch the drones aoc is going to be
like what
huh
no
i don't know and there's not going to be
able to do any of this stuff i think it
should be like fire all those guys that
wouldn't listen to it i want to see
instagram live streams of shopping
that's what i want to see from the white
house how how do you here here's my
here's a problem trying to get to with
donald trump they accuse him of working
with russia it is a ridiculous thing
yeah what are they going to accuse
aussie at doing
she's like she's a look i'm not trying
to be a dick but she's an airhead you
know what i'm you know
she's just
she's not gonna do what they say yeah
what would her scandal be i don't know
what would her scandal be
aoc scandal they try to use to ruin her
or it could just be that she just says
probably partying probably partying do
you think yeah and that's not that's not
very bad or something that's not there's
a lot worse scandals there's people with
with kill list conspiracy theories
attached to them you know they said
reagan wouldn't be president right
they're like a movie star president then
you get donald trump a reality tv real
estate mogul i think ase could win i
really do i just don't think it's likely
if she wins it makes it so much more
likely libertarians have a shot you'll
get a comedian in the white house
why do you think so well you get you're
you're talking about voting for a clown
why are we not having a cool medium
so what's what's happening with the
libertarian party uh do we know do you
have any updates on
who's running
so we don't have any official
announcements but i think in
you just said dave smith you said
comedian right so we don't have any we
don't have official announcements but
the top contenders right now are going
to be dave smith
justin amash and and spike cohen
although he keeps insisting he's not
running he's there's a lot of energy and
support behind him so those are the
those are the three people who i see
falling into that role and there has
been a little bit of a little bit of
whisper and buzz about maj toure maybe
jumping into a v-popup really
that'd be cool
education secretary so i can get into
the department absolutely education
secretary scott horton will be you know
in charge of
foreign policy that would be awesome
like build a mini ramp in the in the in
the uh um
situation room i want to see i want to
see maj turret uh running
running senate and congress you see this
is why he teaches conflict resolution
classes he had one over the weekend so
that you know maybe
press secretary malice absolutely that
that's just what that's that's all i
want
i'm ready he will do it he's going to be
the greatest one bitcoin one bitcoin so
we got the times square billboards up
and we we've included him on them
because you know we're just we're big
fans and i thought it would be great and
then he was he said to me he's like well
at least if we lose we had more fun
and i was like yep
yes i think we're going to do it we want
to see malice as a press secretary we
gotta we gotta start hooking that man up
with one bitcoin per month one bitcoin
per month i mean that's not that much
for a price secretary we we're talking
we're talking like what is that gonna
come out to like
270 a year it's a high salary for for a
government position like that the cap is
174 though per year oh it's it's capped
out you can't thanks no but in a
campaign you can pay more can't you oh
and a campaign yeah yeah campaign so
we'll we'll have to figure something out
worth it
yeah
absolutely i'm putting together an
excellent roster for you all i like how
it's like we're sitting here it's kind
of like you know bsing and then corey's
like i'll be i'll be education secretary
you're like sure
i've got a list it's a good list you're
on the list five years later you are and
we're like man we're just talking smack
the department of ed's gone the next day
i'm firing myself oh yeah
i saw a bar tab from before they signed
the declaration of independence the
founding fathers and it was like
yeah it was like 160 bottles of liquor
for 60 of them you know with some insane
number where they all drink like two and
a half bottles that's amazing they're
all drunk and they're just like screw it
we're independent and they're like yeah
and then they wake up in the morning
like what did i sign
i'll put i'll put reed coverdale in
charge of uh transportation yeah he's a
trucker so
i don't know i know him through twitter
but i've never met him face to face
yeah you know spike cohen is brilliant
he is he's a great articulate messenger
i really he's very humble too i didn't i
had no idea how brilliant like he's a
genuinely nice person
and and i love libertarians but
we're not all nice i don't consider
myself a genuinely nice person i can be
kind of mean i've never seen spike cohen
be mean never so so look there's a new
libertarian party obviously right now oh
yeah you guys took over yeah the old
libertarian party got really crazy
remember when um
um uh
well i'm sorry who was running for
president i forgot her name
joe joe joe jorgensen joe jorgensen when
she when she did that uh marxist
authoritarian statement on twitter oh my
goodness i was like this is the funniest
thing i've ever heard from she said it's
not enough to be not racist we must be
actively anti-racist super sweet lady a
super sweet lady
did not have good uh people on her team
but like it was funny i i thought it was
hilarious the libertarians were telling
us what we must do i know i know
it was very painful it was very painful
what we must
what was the the party's stance on like
the the closures and the lockdowns at
the time so the party did not make a
single statement
not on their website not email not
social media not twitter nothing for an
entire year come on this is your
opportunity this is the time to do this
this is your time to shine ball whiffed
bald whiffed so we have come out uh very
strong opposition under new leadership
to lockdowns uh all manner of mandates
vaccine mandates war
what i don't understand how the liberty
look it sounds to me like the
libertarian party was taken over before
you guys it was it was taken over in
2006 by
the the insider term is prags
pragmatists but you could consider them
as more centrist moderate types
so you could think of it as yangang
without the marketing but they're not
libertarian correct like like i i people
refer to me as lib center libertarian
centrist or whatever and i'm more in
agreement with you guys than oh very
much so no they're they they started out
kind of like moderate oh man so the
history of this is really brutal and i
had to go through recently about 15
years of staff reports to understand
everything that happened so exciting
well really more i went back to 1996. it
will bore you to death but i personally
found it fascinating to watch the party
get taken over by neocons at one point
and and watch membership and fundraising
and interest tank and then get taken
over by woke top woke types and watch it
tank again the reality is libertarians
at large the movement don't want
anything to do with that but these
weirdos got into positions of power
and really soiled the branding and name
and it's just they were more organized
at the time and who knows i i speculate
there why are you libertarian at all
well you're mad at your dad you know so
you don't want to vote the same party as
your dads you pick us instead it's like
you're weird boring centrist rebellion
wow yeah but now we've taken it over
we've taken it back we've taken it back
was it because of the coveted stuff or
was it already in the works we were
working on this uh
we kicked it off at the
summer of 2017. so i was already active
in the party and then was kind of
confused when i saw people coming out
against ron paul in the party i was like
what what what total embarrassment i'm
so
i'm ashamed
this was like the pragues or whatever
yeah
shameful shame i don't understand how
are they against ron paul i don't know
mean words that he had friends they
didn't like someone said something mean
that's not pragmatic at all no it's not
it's not pragmatic it's bizarre weird
culty gatekeeping like you don't have
any friends who've ever said anything
mean that you didn't like in your whole
life
it's an unreasonable
human position thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you